hello everyone my name is Sully I'm a
software engineer here at Google and I'm
very lucky to be joined by Telsey
Hightower the greatest person that I
know
oh I'm putting on that map performance
review that's right Kelsey can you tell
us what you're most excited about a cute
con here this this year you've been to a
lot of coupons yeah we have 8,000 people
here and what I'm noticing is some
people still don't know what cover nays
is so keeping that fresh perspective I
can learn how we should be making it
better what the real problems are right
you know I haven't had to manage
production infrastructure in a few years
now so it's kind of nice to know like
what the real problems are keeping
grounded and just learning from other
people right so lava is considered us
experts right you're expert in the
storage space but then there's things
use cases we don't know so the
opportunity to learn from the community
yeah so I mean I've heard a lot from you
about customer empathy not necessarily
worrying about the engineering problem
but taking time to think about what do
what are the problems that we're
actually solving for customers and in
that perspective you know you've been
asking us to take a step back from
kubernetes and look at the problem more
holistically can you talk about that and
what Google's been doing in the past few
quarters to actually address that yeah
so I think the kubernetes team in
particular any team that's building
doing engineering work in the open you
start to have empathy for all the issues
that get opened right but for me I get
that I get fortunate that I get to go
see our customers and white board and
very rarely do we start with kubernetes
is the solution or the problem it's
usually we want to do these five or six
things so internally you've been a part
of them we do these infancy sessions and
the goal is to take our engineering and
say let's fill it the way our customers
fill it and then we actually start to
see that you know what without even
mentioning kubernetes we all have ideas
on how to solve these problems its bonus
points that we can leverage your
platform like kubernetes to solve them
so I think it's more of how can we make
more people successful sometimes that
involves kubernetes or sometimes that
involves a new thing like sto to solve
that kind of problems so that empathy
sessions is what helped me stay grounded
and focused on what the customer needs
so as you talk to customers now what are
the problems that you're seeing them
encounter that we really need to address
with the community now honestly I think
it's the principles right see ICD has
been a good idea for a long time
it isn't just a
idea because kubernetes came out so what
I try to ask them is this what is your
culture what is your change management
process that's what you're going to
build into this concept called CSC D
it's not about spinnaker versus Jenkins
pick one
once you pick one you're going to
articulate your culture in that I so
people gonna write a set of bash scripts
in a specific order and that's how
you're gonna do things if you're using
raw vm's that will still work when qu
Bearnaise comes in you can eliminate a
lot of stuff that you do in between CI
and kubernetes and then that's the
business thing that you focus on but
then the platform stays the same whether
you're using cloud functions kubernetes
or raw VMs most developers can just
check in code and you hide that
complexity that to me is the principle
that has never changed
I'm telling companies now you need to
get that done do not kick that can down
the road
yes kubernetes is awesome has a lot of
great technologies but if we just go out
and hand out coop seats yell to everyone
we're kind of regressing back to the old
ways of doing things
put CI CD on top and just enjoy the fact
that you're gonna have to do a lot less
glue between see ICD and kubernetes so
that's great advice for developers or
companies to start focusing on CI CD
first and let everything else evolve
from there do you have any other advice
for customers especially those with a
lot of legacy applications and how they
should deal with them and you know think
about this modern world you know it's
funny every customer I mean they say
legacy app so you're not allowed to say
legacy you have to say classic because
it's the legacy stuff that's paying your
paycheck right like that's where it
comes from this is the tried and true so
if you consider it a classic thing you
kind of appreciate it a little bit
better so what I tell them is a lot of
the things that are working will
probably also work in the new world it's
just about where do you adapt right so
in my keynote it's funny I'm going to be
using Fortran right this is one the
original programming languages recently
had a release in 2018 and I'll be using
that to deploy to kubernetes and other
service platforms you should show people
it's not about legacy versus new things
it's more about we've learned things in
the last 30 years
I'll have them are baked into tools like
kubernetes and here's how you leverage
them with some of your existing stuff
sometimes that's a rewrite sometimes
it's retrofit so I want people to focus
more on the principles those last four
even if the product changes and do they
need to do they need to modernize at all
or is that an option than to stay put
where they are so when I think about
modernization if you have an app that
you'd neglect it
you've not updated it you haven't
patched it you're using outdated
software that hasn't anymore support
you're vulnerable there's security
reasons why you need to update that it's
not even about modernization you need to
stay on top of it so software is a
liability once you write some software
it's yours and you got a nurture and
feed it so whether you decide to
leapfrog and say you know what if we're
going to make adjustments to this to
improve security posture maybe we adapt
containers and that gets us there a
little bit of quicker so to me the
modernization is more about there are
new things available that we're not
available before and how are we going to
leverage them and then label that
whatever you want but to me you still
need to do that regardless for security
just so you know how it works but yeah
leverage some of the new stuff make
sense so security is a very very good
reason to not stay put because you will
become a target very quickly yes okay
that makes sense so looking forward into
2019 what are you most excited about
I think 2019 we're starting to settle
I've been looking at the KU Bernays
release notes and a lot of big bang new
features so we're starting to stabilize
and as we stabilize in 2019 I think we
have more people saying the same things
everyone knows are the container is you
know what a pot is I'm kind of starting
to understand networking but we're also
starting to understand what the value -
this is where kubernetes stops this is
where SEO takes over here's where CI CD
plays here's where service starts like
native has given people kind of this
clear line of starting to think about
this functions as a service kind of
thing so I think 2019 we're gonna start
to now get a return on value from this
big open source investment right you've
been working on ku Bernays forever I've
been involved for a very long time and
when you start to look at it's like when
do we start getting a payback on this so
now people using GK II don't even think
about it oh this is security
vulnerability click we've upgraded it
for them so now we're starting to see
return on investment in 2019 and now
we're gonna also start to identify
what's missing right we know what we can
do in combination to improve but there's
a whole layer between just run my code
and what kubernetes does that's 2019
that sounds wonderful
so just to wrap things up let's talk
about cute con I'm gonna put you on the
spot a little bit what's your favorite
cute con memory of all the cute cons
that you've been to you know what the
very first cube come was purely
community there was no CN CF yet there
was no big Cisco
yeah we're just a bunch of people that
got in one spot and we were all betting
it wasn't the number one platform we
were still like is docker swarmed the
way to go is mace is the way to go so we
got in that room and we said hey here's
what we're doing here's how we're trying
and I remember I think Michelle nur Ali
posted the Twitter thing how many people
are running kubernetes on production and
we had them all get on the stage right
and all of them can probably fit right
here we tried to and that was a very
authentic conference right it's like
everyone you had to buy in and now when
you zoom for you can kind of see those
people are still here so we knew that we
built a very strong community in the
very beginning and that's why I can
never forget that that's I think one of
the big reasons that kubernetes is the
scale that it is now is because of the
community that it nurtured and the
leadership that came from the bottom up
basically and I think you played a large
part of that Thank You Kelsey awesome
thank you all right take care
[Music]